Look Me in my eyes and listen birthdays
are tricky Affairs everyone wants their
time to feel celebrated special I work
at an Internet content company with 23
other co-workers that means 24 birthdays
where precisely 4:00 p.m. a box room
belly woz Baker's is delivered to the
front door
a box of birthday cookies 23 chocolate
chip one blue that blue cookie is a blue
velvet orgastic chip cookie the belly
was his specialty you can't Botwin you
only get one on your birthday but every
birthday Tony
the receptionist grabs it no matter
whose birthday it is no matter what
people say he's the blue velvet orgastic
chip cookie until September 16th
September 16th is my birthday and I want
so celebrated happy birthday Henry
sorry Tony super blue velvet orgastic
chip cookie
they're so good but Tony's always takes
it it's not right next week's my
birthday and damn and I want that blue
velvet orgastic chip cookie I would plan
but I need your help to do it your cut
will be half of the blue vote orgastic
chip cookie
you ran why me I trust you to do the
right thing all right where are we going
hey Tony Dougie Amy birthday package
yesterday I don't know let me track
happy birthday Thanks can I brought some
scissors
Thanks
hey Kobe what you got there a birthday
package from my mom hey Tony why don't
you let me take care of these yeah it
sounds like there's a phone call phone
can wait it's birthday cookie time okay
Tony I really think you should answer
the phone what are you doing let go I'm
taking these to the break room it's
Chloe's birthday no this is not
this was all Kobe's idea okay he wanted
me to steal the blue velvet orgastic
chip cookie so that he and I could split
it that birthday bastard yeah yeah but
look let's let's stop fighting and you
and I can slip it cookie forget it that
cookie is mine look look if I don't get
half of this blue velvet orgastic chip
cookie I will ruin this entire box okay
fine we'll split it just don't ruin that
blue velvet orgastic chip cookie one two
oh no they gave me birthday packages
today
once you let me
yes I go to the phone call phone can
wait it's birthday cookie time
stop spinning
look into my eyes and listen
birthdays which would be affair
you